a Whitehouse whistleblower has told
members of Congress under oath that more
than 25 people in Donald Trump's
administration have been denied security
clearances except that they got those
security clearances because after the
denials were issued they were overturned
by Donald Trump people working directly
for Donald Trump the whistleblowers name
is Trisha newbould she has been a White
House security adviser for a very long
time she's worked for Democratic
administrations Republican
administrations and she testified before
the House Oversight Committee that she
and her colleagues researched dozens of
security clearances their research which
they know how to do came back with the
conclusion that they should deny these
dozens of clearances sometimes based on
the risk of the person to be blackmailed
for example sometimes because of the
belief that they were under or subject
to being influenced by foreign powers
sometimes for other reasons and someone
associated with the Trump administration
came in and said we are giving these
people security clearance security
clearances as the case is this is all
backed up with a paper trail of
documents that Trisha newbould provided
to the House panel newbold
is an authority here okay I mean like I
said she's done this for decades she's
worked for Republican presidents for
Democratic presidents this is not
political for her she analyzes the
person and makes a determination should
there be a security clearance granted or
should there not be but she now says
that she has to speak out because she
warned her superiors clearances are
being approved under the Trump
administration that shouldn't be this is
a national security threat and she
claims to have been retaliated against
for speaking up now we don't yet know
the full scope of who this applies to we
know that Jared Kushner and Ivanka Trump
are certainly possibilities based on
what we've learned so far the New York
Times is reporting that John Bolton
Donald Trump's national security adviser
is one of the people about whom the
White House
the House of Representatives rather has
subpoenaed documents which would be
utterly disgraceful I mean imagine if
the National Security Adviser of the
United States one of the top national
security officials maybe the top
national security official would not
ordinarily qualify for a security
clearance and Donald Trump or someone
working for Trump decided to override
that determination in order to give them
a security clearance with access to some
of the most sensitive information that
anyone in government has to deal with it
would be an atrocity there are other
instances we know about where Miss
newbold and her colleagues wrote very
detailed explanations about why this
person or that person shouldn't get a
security clearance and they were
sometimes told to quote not touch the
case and ultimately those security
clearances were approved so this is this
is the politicization of national
security I mean listen in general in
American government national security is
politicized I have no I'm not gonna
pretend to you that under Bush national
security wasn't at all political or that
under Obama national security wasn't at
all political but it's being politicized
in the Trump administration way more
than we have become used to even on our
system the powerful and the wealthy are
controlling every department of
government in way more intrusive ways
than we have become accustomed to noting
that even under standard operating
procedure was controlled by incompetent
buffoons is safe right now
they serve the interests of the people
even less than most administrations they
are even more greedy than most
administrations and I don't know I mean
this is one of those things Pat where is
anything going to happen are there going
to be any consequences here because the
house is you know good for them they're
investigating everything that they
rightly believe should be investigated
but ultimately like what's gonna happen
with this well there should be
consequences and those consequences
should come from Trump supporters and
Republicans because remember they say
that they said that Hillary Clinton was
completely untrustworthy right she
handled sensitive information on a
private email server and thus had no
respect for you know our intelligence
community well Trump and the White House
is doing the exact same thing here and I
think they'll just move the goalposts on
it they'll say that now the intelligence
community is overrun by the deep state
that they're not trustworthy anymore and
the Russian investigation was example
Exhibit A for that so yeah I mean
totally moving the goal posts
everything's different now yeah and of
course I mean the people who you know
Tricia newbould is not even part of the
intelligence community but they'll frame
it that way and they're laughing all the
way to the bank under Trump's tax plan
they shouldn't even be in these
positions in Trump's cabinet and as
National Security Advisor many of them
and we have people who specialize in
security clearances saying there are
dozens of people who should not be
cleared should not have access to this
information and they do and Pat's right
there's one way to hold them accountable
and it's by voting in 2020 period and I
hope every single one of you is going to
do that we all know and have talked
about how mentally exhausting it has
become to keep up with the news lately
because of everything that's been going
on over the last few years which is why
I'm so happy to tell you about one of
today's sponsors simple habit and it's
an app that gives you instant access to
thousands of really good five-minute
guided meditations and I encourage you
to try it for free by going to simple
habit comm slash Pakman each meditation
on simple habit was designed for a
specific purpose like waking up falling
asleep dealing with stress getting
focused for work that you have to do
I've really enjoyed integrating simple
habit into my day especially because
they just make it so easy
each meditation is just five minutes
long different meditations are catered
for whatever you're doing whether you're
driving to work or you're on your lunch
break or you're winding down for the day
we're constantly seeing new research
about how many benefits there are to
meditation and simple habit is the
perfect way for beginners to get started
with meditation but it's also just as
useful for people
already meditate and want a library of
guided meditations right at their
fingertips the app also just won the
2018 Google Play award for best
well-being app I think almost anyone
could hugely benefit from an app like
this you can try it for free for a week
by going to simple habit calm slash
Pakman I put a link underneath this
video